[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dallas regains possession marvin
williams couldn't hang on to the rebound
just went into the game
and up top it is chris jobs porzingis
with the alley-oop finish
just going to lob it up kp does the rest
with a nice finish second look at it it
doesn't change he still goes to the
right
and slams it down with two shots tonight
this is the pull-up there's dorian again
oh what a pass
what a pass from luca he hit him on the
post vinnie smith
catches lays it in and as tight as
career high and scoring
oh that was beautiful oh my goodness
not an easy pass on the glass recently
averaging 14 rebounds in the last 13
games
oh that's nice porzingis that's
nicer oh goodness gracious
i'm not going to shoot it i'm going to
go boo y'all
that is incredible that's nice to start
off
doncic gets a powell screen behind the
back
that's what they love in dallas the
passing ability of lucas
watch this pass i mean this is a thread
the needle type pass and he did it
behind the back
amazing contested the shot very well
but a great player in kawhi leonard is
able to get it up over the top
trey burke in maxine oh big finish
stops poor zinges look at this finish
over the top
of zubats
and an excellent look at it from our
incredible crew here in dallas is doncic
works the foul banks it in and he'll
have a chance for three
but that's what you got to do you got to
find a way to shut your mouth
and begin to play with intensity very
respectful man
now oh they have done that on
inbounds full court situations multiple
occasions this year
and it has worked on multiple occasions
straight possessions
with a stop on this end of the floor for
dallas means the mavericks are defending
well
against a very good offensive time
makes the pass but takes matters into
his own hands with a slam dunk
[Music]
[Applause]
seven foot three center
but these days a seven foot three
basketball player
i'm not even sure he got fouled they
called it on bledsoe
side out between the legs to kleebo
soars to the rim stuffs it at his foul
an incredible play
by luca he's just showing off now
with his left hand cleeva with a good
hard roll but that is some
pass what up it's your boy adam lefkow
do you like that content
i know you like that content hit
subscribe for more of it from bleacher
report